on va accueillir tout de suite la
première relooké c'est isabelle morini
bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vraiment
alors j'ai pensé à tous nos jeunes on
peut avoir une photo déjà belle s'il
vous plaît sur ps qu'on peut avoir une
photo d'isabelle morini-bosc quand elle
est partie quand elle est partie s'il
vous plaît merci aurélie c'est juste une
petite photo à calais voilà alors ils
sont en train de local et il aurait dû
le cas les avants mais voilà c'est la
régir bien sûr vous les connaissez bien
entendu vous connaissez la personne
alors vous je vous dire vous êtes
magnifiques comme ça tremblait vous
n'êtes pas dur puis l'avantagé cheveux à
l'été la moitié de la salle
alors est ce qu'on la trouve cette photo
alors voilà donc regarder quand vous
étiez avons regardé cette belle comme ça
aussi
et là c'est complètement autre chose ils
vous ont vidé melon mais à mon avis deux
permanents alors attention vous ne vous
êtes pas vu alma isabelle morini bosc
oui c'est salma hayek oui c'est puis
arrête tes conneries plus tôt alors vous
êtes magnifique je vous le dis vous
allez avoir un choc mais mettez vous
bien devant le miroir attention serait
mieux si je la prenais grecque non non
non voilà attention
[Applaudissements]
ayant bien
nous avons pu vous à des niveaux comment
pouvez vous plaise ou pas je pense que
je sers nourrissent ça vous plaît ou pas
les saints non d'accord le reste oui à
tout le reste oui la coupe et la
perruche je rêve d'avoir des cheveux
longs et lisses donc moi j'ai cru que ma
passion salon milieu de semaine
prochaine sur la sauce pas d'accord
merci isabelle morini-bosc allons bâtir